How do you use artificial intelligence to help you
if you are a graduate student or in your work? The topic is fun
and useful, and what you will learn now will be much superior
to others. So focus with me because today we will talk about the
one you ask questions and he will answer you with answers that are
at the heart of the topic and the answer that you actually
want to reach with just a question and answer. We will talk
today.  About the one based on if you heard about it, and
this version is the most recent version and it is
more enjoyable, and at the same time it is able to produce many results for you linked to the
search engine between you and Villa. Let us
start with some of today’s video. It has three sections. The
first part is why we use
and write the normal search and see the results. The second thing is
how to connect
and use it, and the third thing.  General ideas for using
Focus with us. Today's video will make a huge difference
to you. It is necessary to use it and not be lazy because this is the
future. Whatever you want, let's go.
Peace be upon
you. Omar Mohsen. I come to the first question: Why do I use Bing or Chat and get the result? Here is an example: I am staying in the
city of Riyadh for 3 days, for example.  I want to know what
things I can do there. I will try
Google's search and try and this
was the result of his. Adani is still one of
the sites and I choose one of them and I see Google offers me the common search and
choose from them. Then I
enter and deter, but between GI Adani
told me the first day what you will do, the
second day what you will do.  And on the third day, what will you do? I
think this is a sufficient answer, and I do not need to fear
more details than that. We come to the second part: How do I get to the
bank? I collected for you all the links available in the
video description. The first thing we will open the link in the
Edge browser and download the program according to the
operating system. After you finish it, you will open it in a browser.  And you
go to work and log in. If you have an email on
Outlook, write it here and log in. If you do not have it,
create a new one. For example, we choose
and write Omar, for example, any number, and so on. And you create your
email. The same steps you do when
creating an email. I will not go into the details of
creating the email after we have created the email
and entered.  Just like we made a login, we will go and find a
chat tab above it. Click on it and
it will open this field for you. He will click on “Confirm
that you are logging in” and it will begin to put you on
a list. Within a day or two, it will begin to
enter you on any, and this actually happened to me. This is the
form of an email that came to me after only two days from
Entering Lush is not a
quick look at Bing Bank, it is a browser exactly
like Google. For example, I am searching
here for I want to stay for a week in Alexandria, so create
a plan for me
in the search engine. It is normal to notice that it is here
giving me results exactly like Google. But the
beautiful part remains.  On the right, this is the
chatbot or something
like that. He writes to me about the things that I like. If
I am interested in history and all these things, he would like
Qaitbay Citadel. If I am interested in the beaches, I go to the park, and so on. This is a quick response
from him, and he gave me the sources from which he brought me
these results.  Someone from Deh tells
me exactly the site from which he got this information and
the browser after the last update. I will notice that he
also brought me here. It is still available in the browser
directly. You can search for it and write what you want.
Okay, so we have finished the chat and finished
everything. We want to go to the new section
called Chat.  It is the place where I write
my questions and he answers them. We will click on I will
notice that he appears to me above and leaves the same
words that I was writing. It is in the
chat, which is the question: Make me a plan for
Alexandria in a week. It has three types. It
is possible that he will create his own answers,
which will be in the same time.  Time contains information.
If you talk about numbers, facts, and things like this, it is not
useful because it leaves room for manipulation. You choose how to
respond to you. Let
us try the rest of the questions like this together. I will write the same question, but put it in the end. Make me the questioner’s line for the trip to
Alexandria. What I
liked is that his interface is fun.
At the same time, he is able to put pictures in it and put
all these things, and this is not currently available in
the chat. We press Enter and we will notice that he is using Bing’s search to
show me his results. Do you see what he is
doing here? He tells me that the
first day you will wake up in the morning and make chicken in your
hotel, which is  For example, in the afternoon, you will
go to the Alexandria library, and at night you will go to eat
in one of the strong restaurants on the
Mediterranean, and
so the topic is very rigid. Do you see how the schedule seems organized? Of course, if you consult each one of this, you will come and
tell me
what his sources are, which are located below. Of course, I do
not want it.  More answers than that. Can I
click on a man? I told him that he considered
six days to be very good. A while ago, there were sources on
Alexandria, pictures, and all of these things. If I clicked on More, he
would start answering me about the city of Alexandria. The
Travel section is available in a browser in the search of
Gemayel Bank.  If you notice this topic
here, it is one of 15. This means that I can
talk to him about the same topic that I asked
above. I mean, here he has given me six days. On the
fifth day, I do not want to go to the park, so I can
tell him here. He also invited me. Of course, here are ready-made responses.
Yu Chen Smaktivity On
Day, then I tell him, “This is the
fifth day. I don’t want to go to the park. I don’t want to
go to the park. I want to go to another place because there are 5 ways, for
example, Norse Coast.” I mean, this is the fifth day. I
want to go to the North Coast, for example, and I press Enter.
It will depend here.  On the first question and he completes it with the
answer, he can complete up to 15 answers
and questions between you and the ping, that is, if you notice
here, one of the 15
people responded to me. He said to me, “On the fifth day, I loved it for you on the Nawras Coast.” He said to you, “You will take a bus from Al-Alamin, and it will take
from an hour to an hour and a half, and it will go. I
don’t know where it is, to be honest.”
Very rigid and you prefer to play as you want. Note here
two out of 15 have changed. Okay, I don't understand.
Everything that was mentioned above is written in
English. What translation do you want in Arabic? Of course, if your
English is not the best thing, you can go to
Google Translate and write what you
want in Arabic and English.  Or you speak to him at length in
Arabic, but the results in Arabic are not as
strong as in English. To be honest, so far, of course,
the future can change. I told him, “I am Arabic
here.” He asked me, “Do I want to translate just what was past or all of the itinerary?” And here he started translating the itinerary into Arabic.
Another example at work. He came up, for example, an email and a text message.
I am responding to him or I do not have an answer or the
topic will take me a while, so I can take the
entire Cuban email and go to anyone who translated it for
me. That's it. Here I want to go to any and
create a new topic. Create a new topic and put it in. I
tell him please
email. I will take the copy email and put it on.  Yes, yes, and I
tell him to reply to me on this e-mail. I did not even
tell him to reply with what. You can reply and tell him to reply, for example, in the affirmative, in the negative, agree, refuse, and he starts to
receive the right in a professional manner, and we click on the question, “Oh,
and I sent him
how to cook paneer chicken.” Let us try this, for example, “how do I
cook paneer chicken.”  What are the requirements? The man
replied to you and told you what things
you need. This is the way. You want to know
more details, of course, sources. You can tell him, for example,
bread and so on. He has a little bit of this in your hand. Examples and don’t
write what you want. It is a very interesting topic.
Guys, we can tell him to write an article for me about
Ramadan.
By the way, if I don't agree with you, you can also repeat
the question in another way or write again and I will
answer you with different answers each time about the
kiss and taking this video. Bing above that there is a
possibility that you can create pictures inside the
chat of the
topic. You can reach it simply by writing
and what you want, which is  He will make it for you
directly, but unfortunately I have finished with my question. How to
reach the topic of these pictures directly. They will go
to the web site Pink. It will
take you to this place. This is the place where you write what you want and it will show you a picture of it. You will have it here.
This will increase every day. It will remain 25 at the
beginning of each.  About ten days will certainly change in
the future, meaning that you wait five minutes
every time you request a photo, or if you want to replenish
your points through what are
reward points, you will do some things like this, and you will receive them from you. You will
do a search for things and purchases, and you will have points
and use them here or they will work.  You can
do it with
only five. These are examples of the things that have been done, and here he
will explain to you how it works. The most important thing in the thing
you are writing must be that it has the
design style that you want. Of course, as you can see, frankly,
awesome things can be done, and I have already tried it.  I
finished mine, but I didn't write it right. Let me show you
what I did. I'll
go and he actually made these forms for me,
as you can see. I can open them. I can share with her that I have
her regrets on the device. I can
download her or tag her on social media. I
wrote a simple thing to do.  I have a cat
wearing BR glasses as you see,
and so I told him I want someone waiting for water in
the desert. Send me pictures as you see. It is a little
strange, but perhaps if I added more words, it would be
better than that. I mean, let me see what
your creativity is in using Bing.
You asked her and what her answers are in the
comments below, and please don't be lazy because the
topic is very useful. This is the future, whether you like it
or not. After that, the people who will come and tell you, "I'm doing a search, uncle. You can ask a question
along the way. You're coming very old, even though this search
was a new thing after that."  We were not looking at
these books for the jobs that will be replaced in
the future, as expected from Chad GPT,
so that you stay away from them or try to develop your
skills in them. If you are
currently in them, I will see you, God willing, a new video.
Peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon you.